snaking traffic on snarled up roads
all of it heading one way towards the
ferry terminal at dover
with it came inevitable frustration
we've been in a queue for about seven
and a half hours so heading to spain
today so we should have been on a
crossing at ten to eight so as you can
see we're severely delayed very
frustrating
three hours in traffic queues
i
should have been on our ferry an hour
ago
two and a half hours been waiting and
sang it about well you just you know
you've got 50 yards and you stopped for
20 minutes 50 yards yeah he's thinking
about now it's going to be better but
it's been ridiculous really
for the driver of this lorry
temperatures were running high
absolutely ridiculous
all the cars
are now in the freight lanes
the reason it all ground to a halt
according to port officials was woefully
inadequate staffing at the french border
where passports have to be shown before
getting on the ferry
i am really very sorry to all those
travelers that have that have headed out
this morning to the truck drivers the
local community in dover we should not
be in this position
we have we have been planning for this
day this morning
for the last several months for what we
had required for this morning there was
insufficient officers
on the ground ready to do the work and
the processing times through the border
were also much longer than normal
in preparation for the big summer
getaway the port of dover say they'd put
in 50 percent more border control booths
and had spoken in granular detail with
the french authorities about exactly
when was likely to be most busy and yet
still we've got gridlock
as a result a critical incident was
declared
but the police across the channel deny
that the french authorities were to
blame instead saying an unexpected
technical incident under the channel
tunnel was somehow the cause although
that's been refuted by the tunnel's
operators
as ever caught up in the chaos of the
summer rush of the people of this town
one car even resorted to driving along
the pavement
getting there is going to be a bit of a
problem with some of them and these
healthcare assistants who provide
end-of-life and palliative care to
clients in their homes had to find a way
to get to them despite the mayhem
it's been really difficult today we've
had to walk to calls
we've had to prior to prioritize our
clients to make sure which ones need
help first we've had to
well to make sure medications taken on
time that's been a difficult one
as the day progressed the traffic eased
but for those heading off on holiday it
was an unwelcome start to their summer
break